let's do some audience questions we've
got really good ones this week let's
jump right in Ryan wrote in saying hey
guys is contemporary art really art or
is it just artists trolling for money
and attention okay we've talked a little
bit about the whole contemporary art
avant-garde art thing so let's first
start with a definition of art alright
from the dictionary art is the
expression or application of human
creative skill and imagination typically
in a visual form such as painting or
sculpture producing works to be
appreciated primarily for their beauty
or emotional power so I think that with
the with the broad definition of art as
read contemporary art is art now I
understand some people might say well if
I urinate on a canvas and then sprinkle
sawdust on it to stick to the urine and
then I put that up on the wall as a
painting that's not really art it's me
urinating on a canvas but I would argue
that if it's visually compelling if the
visual combined with the story about it
makes people look and say that's
interesting then it is art in that sense
right so there's two sides here one is
on the artist who is putting something
forward that's creative and took a good
amount of skill for them to produce and
then the other side is completely
subjective what the person taking in the
art thinks of it so how could I tell
someone that they weren't emotionally
affected by the piece that they saw or
something I don't think I'm in a
position to say that something is there
is an art if it was really easy to
produce that sometimes people will look
at like a Jackson Pollock painting and
say listen I could do that I'm just
going to splash paint up there and in
fact years ago on the Howard Stern Show
they did something where I think it was
Howard or someone else did some [ __ ]
type paintings and they showed them to
people compared to actual Pollock
paintings most people couldn't tell the
difference right the Pollock the Pollock
asked painting created by Howard Stern
was indistinguishable to you know non
art specialists from actual Pollock
paintings but I don't think that that
really proves anything because it's much
easier to copy a style that has been
developed that is different than
creating something from scratch so I
don't even know that that necessarily
disproves it there is lots of
guard and contemporary art that doesn't
resonate with me right so like for
example things made from trash where
sometimes I say wow that's really
interesting you've created radios from
old trash okay that's that's cool or
wallets I find that artistic and
interesting but then sometimes you'll
have a picture which is just of like a
piece of plastic that someone has left
on the ground it's photography there's
no doubt that by its definition is art
it might not resonate with me but who am
I to say that this is not art exactly
it's like you may not have an interest
in a specific topic like you're not
watching the makeup tutorials on YouTube
yeah but you understand there's a market
for it and other people can appreciate
that in their different ways this always
seems to gain a lot of attraction when
someone puts forward a canvas with maybe
a red dot and a splash of blue on it and
it sells for thousands of thousands of
dollars and people wonder why would
anyone pay that much money but if the
person buying the art is willing to do
that that's totally fine I should
actually do that I just got some new
paint because I've been you know getting
into acrylic painting off and on for a
while and I'm terrible I should take a
canvas and I should just paint I have a
color called I think it's like titanium
or something like that it's like an
off-white I should paint the entire
thing off-white and then place a blue
dot and a red square on it maybe
somebody wants that right I mean maybe
there may be the placement that comes
instinctually to me you will really
speak to someone and how could anyone
say that it's not art you know that's up
to them it's the percept the perception
of the value right art is in the eye of
the beholder acting as what we're trying
to say all right so there's my answer I
have no problem with contemporary art
even if it doesn't appeal to me how can
I say something is not art